a long-awaited casino resort in the
southwest valley moves one step closer
to reality the project known by many as
durango station has been in the works by
station casinos for years as orco mana
shows us surrounding neighbors do have
some concerns
[Music]
the community of spring valley vocal at
tuesday night's town advisory board
meeting some for and some against the
project known as durango station the
project before you proposes a much less
intense use a real estate attorney
representing station casinos explained
the scope of the casino project at
durango and the 215 to a crowd of about
50 people we are presenting a plan to
you
that includes over just over 400 hotel
rooms and a reduction in gaming for
space to approximately 99 000 square
feet it'll also include 20 thousand
square feet of outdoor dining space it's
really going to be advantageous i
believe those in favor of durango
station say it's a benefit to the
community we're all for it the
restaurants the
gaming shows whatever else might show up
there but some like deborah korak are
worried about how much traffic in the
area will increase especially with
schools near the properties proposed
entrances kids are not careful about
crossing the street and and the traffic
on mall street has significantly
gotten worse korak says if the casino
entrances are not adjusted then i don't
think it should go up still the spring
valley town advisory board approved the
plans also recommending developers look
at any improvements we will be working
through any traffic concerns with staff
orc omana 8 news now
in a statement about these latest
concerns station casinos tells us in
part quote our new development will be a
great addition and a great community
partner employing thousands of
construction and full-time team members
and creating tens of millions of dollars
in new state and local taxes
claire county commissioners will meet
next month to make a final decision